[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión nos lleva a reino unido país que
tomó la decisión de salir de la unión
europea hace más de un año el 23 de
junio de 2016 el 50 y 1.89 por ciento de
los británicos votó a favor de abandonar
el bloque fuertemente dividido el país
se embarcó entonces en un largo y
complejo proceso de negociaciones el 31
de enero de 2020 reino unido- dejó
oficialmente la unión europea luego
inició un período de transición de 11
meses que permitió a las empresas
prepararse para la era post preside
actualmente sobre el terreno persisten
los desacuerdos entre londres y bruselas
sobre varios temas entre ellos la pesca
y el protocolo de irlanda del norte las
casas de la mano de obra se sienten en
muchos sectores como la construcción la
restauración o la salud nuestros
periodistas viajaron a londres belfast y
boston para conocer el impacto del break
city en la vida cotidiana
porque este hilo está todavía enredado
estamos trabajando en temas relacionados
con el éxito pero no con el éxito como
tal porque todo es pasado esta batalla
ha terminado gracias a dios y gano y así
hemos vencido todos los pronósticos la
victoria más inesperada de los tiempos
modernos
esta era la cara del break si está la
lucha de toda una vida para nadie el
farac
hoy ha dejado la política tradicional
para convertirse en presentador de
televisión en el nuevo canal de noticias
británico de extrema derecha
[Música]
la respuesta es mordaza
si quieren pagar mi factura de gas y
electricidad adelante
no soy un niño rico como nick clegg o
david cameron
tengo que ganarme la vida como lo haría
sin sueldo o ingresos
su sueño dice no es dirigir el país con
haber salido de europa le basta para ser
feliz una felicidad que está lejos de
ser compartida por todos para entender
mejor las consecuencias del break shit
viajamos por el reino unido- primera
parada basildon a unos 40 km de londres
pasado a sandra instrucciones para el
día el proyecto de 6 millones de libras
debía permitir la expansión de su
empresa familiar pero proyecto se ha
convertido en un dolor de cabeza tardará
cinco años en lugar de los dos previstos
deberíamos tener al menos 90
trabajadores en este sitio en lugar de
eso somos 10
pero
si no vuelven
aquí se fueron a otros países
el empresario londinense recibe la
visita de dos antiguos empleados humanos
ahora tiene que convencerles de que
participan en el proyecto
aceptan su oferta con un aumento de
sueldo del 20% pero están preocupados
por su futuro
el break si nos afecta a todos estamos
tristes
mis hijos nacieron aquí tienen 6 y 8
años imagínense que después de 10 años
aquí nos dijeran que nos fuéramos a casa
por culpa del break solo mis hijos no
saben nada de romania y ni siquiera
hablan bien el idioma es triste por el
momento tengo los papeles para quedarme
en inglaterra pero es un permiso de
residencia temporal
no estoy seguro el 100% de que vaya a
quedarme para siempre pero ese es mi
objetivo
[Música]
él preside ha provocado una escasez de
mano de obra en muchos sectores
construcción agricultura servicios
consecuencias a los precios
lo que la gente no entiende son las
consecuencias de esto su trabajo las
remuneraciones de los apartamentos todo
costará más podremos construir todas las
viviendas que necesita el pueblo inglés
si lo piensas por un minuto puedes ver
que la inmigración es positiva para la
sociedad publicamos avisos en la prensa
para atacar a personas nacidas en
inglaterra y en cinco años sólo hemos
contratado a un inglés los demás
vinieron dijeron que era demasiado duro
que hacía demasiado frío
es cierto que el clima inglés no es muy
bueno y se fueron enseguida
desde el referéndum el break sido ha
sido objeto de mucho debate y
controversia partidarios y opositores
quieren ahora avanzar para nadie para su
eslogan de campaña recuperar el control
se ha hecho finalmente realidad praxis
el break sheet consiste en poder
gobernarnos a nosotros mismos en
controlar nuestras leyes decidir cómo se
dirige nuestra gente y otras empresas
william sirven garantiza el éxito es
posible fracasar pero uno tiene la
oportunidad de hacerlo bien y mejor
le prometo que si viene conmigo a las
provincias verá que los ingleses vienen
espontáneamente a darme la mano ya darme
las gracias al final de cuentas el break
sí fue realmente una lucha entre londres
y el resto del país
un símbolo de la inglaterra seducida por
el mensaje de far as is boston
en su día fue una ciudad próspera que
dio nombre a su ciudad hermana
estadounidense en la costa este
esta fue la ciudad que más votó por el
break shit sin embargo aquí el rechazo a
europa era sobre todo el rechazo a la
inmigración según el ex alcalde antón
dani
nacido en marruecos ha vivido en francia
e islandia pero nunca está donde se
espera que esté from
my friends with the day
y ni siquiera me escucha
es una familia polaca clientes míos
son jóvenes y quieren integrarse y
trabajar en la comunidad es difícil
porque hay gente en boston que no los
aceptan
pero las cosas están cambiando
lentamente sus hijos hablan inglés y eso
es lo que queremos
aceptamos todas las personas así
antón se acaba de enterar de la llegada
de nuevos inmigrantes a su ciudad
no cambia mucho con el break
porque siguen llegando extranjeros
les diré algo a gente de kazajistán que
está en las granjas en este momento
trabajan bien así que los trajeron
completados solo por seis meses
siempre tenemos gente nueva esa es la
diversidad
[Música]
el consejero regional de lincolnshire y
propietario del café de parís cree que
los recién llegados deben integrarse
mejor
la mayoría de ellos ven canales de
televisión de esos países
donde compras a sus propias tiendas no
vienen a la ciudad
esto se debe a que el gobierno no gasta
nada para integrarlos no se les enseñan
nuevos valores leyes o idiomas solo
vienen a trabajar
yo diría que es la mentalidad inglesa de
decir que somos la nación superior no
nos importa
es cierto que en la década anterior al
referéndum el número de extranjeros
instalados en boston se había
cuadruplicado las caras de la ciudad
había cambiado y también la de su
juventud una vez a la semana los niños
se reúnen para una clase de karate y con
un profesor voluntario
es virginia gotzis está aquí para
desafiar las ideas preconcebidas
no sé cuántos tiempo llevan en boston
pero probablemente hayan oído hablar de
los problemas entre comunidades
estamos en contra de todo esto tenemos
niños de todas partes
demuestra que todos podemos convivir y
ser amigos
algunos padres están viendo las clases a
no se está preparando para elecciones
dominadas para obtener el permiso de
residencia
[Música]
es una excelente oportunidad para que
nuestros jóvenes crezcan aprendiendo
respeto y disciplina
les muestra que si uno se esfuerza puede
lograr grandes cosas y triunfar en la
vida
el objetivo de los break sitters menos
inmigración y más soberanía
sin embargo el divorcio es más
complicado de lo esperado bruselas y el
reino unido- están negociando o incluso
chocando sobre todo por el protocolo de
irlanda del norte- creado hace un año y
ya ha denunciado por londres evita una
frontera física entre el norte y el sur
de irlanda desgarrada por 30 años de
guerra civil entre católicos y
protestantes
con este protocolo las normas cambian
para las mercancías que salen de puertos
ingleses o escoceses como caerían y se
dirigen a irlanda del norte londres y
bruselas han trazado una frontera
invisible en medio de este mar europa
quiere proteger su mercado común a toda
costa y evitar la competencia desleal
con un reino unido- que podría traer
productos a través de irlanda del norte
por ello algunas de las mercancías sobre
todo las agrícolas y animales deben
cumplir las normas comunitarias y
aduaneras para entrar en irlanda del
norte importar también implica más
trámites administrativos por lo tanto
irlanda del norte tiene un estatus muy
especial integrado en el mercado común a
diferencia del resto del reino unido
los unionistas como edwin poots están
furiosos el ministro encargado de los
controles aduaneros muy conservador los
rechaza
no hay tantos controles como estaba
previsto y la unión europea- lo ha
denunciado
en concreto no abra todos los controles
que quieren porque no tengo suficiente
personal veterinario
y no pienso desplegarlo desviando lo de
sus otras tareas
la unión europea no está contenta con la
forma en la que estamos llevando a cabo
los controles bueno seguirá siendo así
hasta que consigamos un acuerdo
razonable
en el centro de belfast una ong intenta
relacionar con los jóvenes tentados por
la violencia vil y educador recuerda los
enfrentamientos entre protestantes y
católicos algunos de ellos recientes
[Música]
en abril hubo graves estudios entre las
dos comunidades cuando cada uno intentó
cruzar la reja para gritar
sino también irlanda del norte de esto
esto sucedió por el protocolo porque hay
descontento ahí no se escucha al pueblo
ni a nuestros políticos el mensaje es
peligroso especialmente en esta
comunidad que cree que los republicanos
llevan décadas obteniendo ventajas
medianas gracias
a uno y los muros separan a los
republicanos católicos y a los
unionistas protestantes las puertas se
cierran incluso por la noche un signo de
la fractura aún presente a pesar de los
acuerdos de paz del viernes santo
apegados a la corona británica
muchos unionistas temen la reunificación
de irlanda a largo plazo
no se respetaron los acuerdos del
viernes santo el concepto del reino
unido todo se ha tirado a la basura crea
inestabilidad y hoy en una comunidad
como la nuestra una historial de
violencia esto es realmente peligroso
el protocolo norirlandés también tiene
implicaciones económicas algunas
empresas sufren las consecuencias de la
nueva normativa para los productos
procedentes del reino unido brook vent
en cambio está encantado la fábrica de
los suministros de belfast produce
ventiladores mecánicos
todo este material viene directamente de
otras partes del reino unido- juntamos
lo que tenemos allí y obtenemos el
producto final es difícil importar estas
piezas desde el reino unido en absoluto
no hay ningún inconveniente
el único problema que tuvimos fue en
febrero porque el proveedor no había
llenado bien los formularios
administrativos
la cartera de pedidos está a tope
con clientes en europa y la república de
irlanda que han duplicado su volumen de
negocio en un año
el protocolo norirlandés resultante de
las negociaciones de interés y nos
ofrece grandes oportunidades no sería
bueno que desapareciera protocolo nos
brinda oportunidades únicas en
comparación con otras funciones del
reino unido pues comercia libremente con
el mercado europeo es decir 450 millones
de personas y al mismo tiempo hacer
negocios con los 67 millones de personas
del reino unido en total es un mercado
de 500 millones de personas
los norirlandeses se sienten a veces que
el primer ministro boris johnson se ha
olvidado de ellos en las negociaciones
del príncipe en londres el gobierno
tiene que hacer frente tanto a la
pandemia del joven 19 como la salida de
la unión europea dos cuestiones que
preocupan a sophie una estudiante
alemana
este es mi suéter europeo es especial
porque le falta una estrella
demuestra que existe la posibilidad de
que europa sea aún más fuerte
la estrella que falta está en la parte
de atrás es el brics y
solo hay que devolverlo al círculo
junto con sus amigos británicos hace
campaña por el regreso del reino unido a
la unión europea
quieren volver a la unión europea no
sabemos qué es
la unión europea es un colectivo de
naciones que luchan
si queremos volver
no sucederá mañana no estamos diciendo
que vaya a suceder mañana solo
intentamos promover una hoja de ruta si
se le dice a la gente que hay que darse
estos pasos verán que es posible y que
una manera de llegar
sin embargo es difícil imaginar la
reincorporación del reino unido- a la
unión europea el país ha elegido otro
camino hacia una mayor independencia
pero el horizonte no está nada claro un
año después los contornos del presi
siguen sin estar claros y también sus
consecuencias para la vida británica
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta que nos llevó a conocer
los impactos del brasil recuerde que si
quiere ver este y otros episodios en
español puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom